domingo terá todo meu nome é ana rita
ela traz drogas aqui um trem da história
da minha vida aqui atrás de mim tal meu
bisavô joaquim paulino um homem que era
melhor piloto era o homem que fazia o
sal nas marinhas no outro observou de
nome joão dá essa razão ela era um homem
também conhecido em aveiro pela sua
famosa casa dizem ir situada junto do
rossio
atualmente causa da ria era na casa das
enguias do meu bisavô fazia as enguias
creche e 20 dias
lembrei que este tradicional
tradicionais da madeira agora já existem
réplicas de trabalhos desta casa e
posteriormente foi à casa de meus avós e
é nessa casa onde estão as minhas mais
fortes recordações e memórias ligadas à
ria de aveiro principalmente no
cheirinho e os gostos da comida feita
pela minha avó como por exemplo as
enguias fritas os pessoais por ria de
aveiro também ficarão sempre presente
centrada em toda a família observa os
mísseis eram pela rios até são jacinto e
muitas vezes na proa do barco e uma
prima vou manuel real é um homem que era
um grande defensor da ria de aveiro
muito lembrado pela gente da ria e já na
altura um grande visionário
lembro de ir muitas vezes as marinhas
dos meus avós eram proprietários das
mesmas o sal estava sempre presente terá
trânsito todos os anos pelo mar do tua
para casa em grandes sacos e eram sal
grosso muito branquinha e cristalino o
nosso sol de aveiro e nas marinhas
também nos álbuns havaianos
contemplávamos aquela beleza toda eu era
muito pequenininho lembro de correr
pelos muros das marinhas e muitas vezes
no pescoço jogava e quem e dentro destes
tanques de água este tanque cheio de
água já estava cristalizar parte aquela
partícula quebrava o que entrava era uma
sensação muito estranha porque lembrou
aquela água morna né
era o mago assim como que oleosa era é
moira mas não havia tempo suficiente se
eu tinha com por andar porque acaba
estragando o trabalho do governo e
certamente que eu não iria gostar ver o
trabalho dos dragados
havia também e tenho muitas recordações
tirar a bola da área
fiz sempre que a marinha se viu muito
sol aqui é um mundo criado não vai haver
aqui um monte de grande que não
estávamos habituados a ver a entrada da
cidade e financeira tirada conosco
ensina e era uma lembrança quem é daqui
da áfrica e américa e certamente também
e tem uma madrinha uma marinha não é
mais do que uma obra de engenharia feita
pelo homem é ver valeu uma uma obra
quase regimento ricamente perfeita
isto é o processo passa simplesmente
pela evaporação da água do mar para
formar os cristais de sal na verdade
para se conseguir a concentração
necessária a cristalização e para
discutir também a tentação dos sites
quer ferro na calcinha em gesso água tem
que passar ao longo de vários técnicos
designados pálios essa ação da gravidade
ora não é só a salvação da gravidade é
esse mito sobre a ação do homem
o maior nó tu é muito engraçado porque o
bernô tu empiricamente consegue explicar
tudo isso processo que no fundo é um
processo físico químico sem esquecer se
dar conta dos seus fundamentos teóricos
um minuto consegue nos dizer é que
temperatura que está agora que o talho
temperatura que um cita sem ter um
termômetro um minuto consegue dizer é
que a altura que está agora aqui outro
talho sem ter uma régua e consegue um
dance entre dizer e dance da daquela
maneira isso tudo pra conseguir obter o
sol e pouca qualidade porque eu pretendi
isso é um trabalho que decorre entre
meados de março e meados e meados de
setembro
é em um trabalho que requer muita força
física mas acima de tudo requer alguns
haverá muita dedicação e muita paixão e
porque hoje o tema da minha conversa
aqui convosco e sauna alma eu trago os
dois homens aqui são dois testemunhos de
dois maus sorri e haver que aceitar o
convite de chocó dois homens têm
verdadeiramente salvar a alma ao senhor
joão ruivo marta 49 anos número 18 e o
senhor antónio silva que faz parte
também das minhas memórias de infância
pois há 20 anos trabalhava na marinha os
meus avós e que neste momento
olhando a maioria dos professores vamos
ouvir os san antonio uma nova da silva
já soma no total 23 anos já trabalha no
início a gente desde 2003 anos em que
impulsionou o jogo dos oito segmentos
toda a gente conhece nesse aspecto a
primeira safra que eu fiz a marinha foi
a 49 anos atrás é um pra mim é um
espetáculo onde andei um porto vitor
augusto garante a linha e ouvia coisa
pra quem gosta diz que tem que ter amor
arte o que a gente faz é que ninguém
agora temos a parte de limpeza strange
dura chamas três dura para as marinhas
preparar as brigas pois parece que era o
dia certo é mais ou menos o índice 11
depois são joão são pedro ela estava em
prontinhos para interação com as bolsas
feitas com vedação de água 25 graus
mas até chegar a esse ponto tem sido as
cores da marinha que nada sei que a
resposta vai mais deixar secar a marinha
e depois de fumar águas pouco a pouco
até chegar à água ganhar a gravação que
os 25 graus
duas parte temos uma lenta e temos o
corpo da marinha o mandamento é
constituído pelo viveiro aos vesical
deles o câncer está lhes possui câncer
numa só palavra do momento em que o
corpo da menina temos um forte símbolo
de nova york e boston nova partida valia
para o pastorinho velho
só fazemos a parte velha eurides fracas
aquelas tema alma maior e então já faz
algumas câmeras do posto pra mim é
trabalhar com água é trabalhar com água
g levarmos a água dos dois graus poveira
depois vai passando pelo andamento dos
olhos vezes goleiros o cruzeiro está
disposto a não ser por eu acho e ela vai
embora chorando e vai ficar no tranco
água está poluída por natureza e eu
postar no andamento
a água também vai filtrando mais um puro
água
portanto nós vamos ter um saldo a alta
qualidade lá por fins de junho
princípios de julho do tempo está a
funcionar mal a gente não o fim não ter
uma linha salto
34 dias pontilharam começar o que chama
o spinning e é pouquinho pronto e 26
canestrini amauri está um pouco mais
possivelmente com mais animais pois há
três dias e ainda não fiz mais meninos
por 1363 disso chove já traz já traz a
favor da prisão pois não era limpar tudo
também novamente explorar com o tempo em
algum ponto na agua trabalhar para
tornar o momento fazer só a chuva for
assim ó quina que não faz assim muito
longe do topo lei michael oenning o
canal entre os meios a gente vamos parar
um pouco e o tempo conforme ela veio em
cima vamos pra que ela vai por cima
novamente a evaporação
vamos fazer uma limpeza de ouro e vamos
continuar a processar se vai beijo no
trecho vamos voltar à estaca zero com
uma versão naval é harley melhor puro
temos sempre bem dispostos convidamos
sim com a mãe das meninas uns com os
outros eo pessoal eu já terá que
trabalhar neste ramo é mal tatiana muito
nisto porque a gente nova hoje em dia
não quer essa vida a vida buscando a
vida muito trabalhosa uma vida dura na
semana não tinha temos família precisa
aprender e ter o rosto faz na profissão
as marinhas depois disto uma vida
amorosa no tempo do solo é bonito
trabalhar com os hawiye é bonito ver ou
as regras com salve branco e aveiro com
as coisas moreninhas que estão agora as
poucas que a minha história bonita
sempre contente e alegre foi
estranhamente talvez das profissões
melhores do mundo pra mim
os outros não porque o salão e voltamos
no tempo das curas
o que eu tenho das curas vocês talvez
não saibam de muitas curvas e agora está
a duas fases
temos um tempo das curas de termos o
tempo sal e no tempo das curas todos os
luxos que juju estavam cinco vezes ao
longo de cinco meses no tempo das coisas
do coração tá você entrou em tudo o que
fazia quando nem o sal o salão branco
fazia o coração preto e muito o tenho o
solo fugiu porque era muito
posso trabalhar amanhã disco soltadas
serem até os sons puro mostrou a
trabalhar com alegria com gosto com seu
disfunção andújar livre antes calçou nem
calçou jogo entrou quilos e tinha muita
luz um mergulho na ria estouros kahn que
se é melhor ou pior coisa pode haver nos
autos é um salto enorme em salang
tratado todos os dias é uma maneira ruim
da mexida é a olhá lá quando já estão
velhas bem mais novas e fazendo tal mais
branquinho
nós temos um salto 84 minerais nos
cutista ferro magnésio prata platina até
lá tudo nós precisamos salvar viver
se nós começamos um pouquinho de sal
grosso nós não precisamos de andar com
praticamente nenhum substituir o sal é t
no mesmo dia está acabado
quando eu comecei a trabalhar e há 49
anos atrás tínhamos cerca de 360 marinha
que já funcionava em teoria da lei pois
tem 17
hoje é muita gente conhece o o o
trabalho havia administrado um
trabalhoso esse trabalho
então muita gente conhece atual valor
estava que estava no trabalho
para amorim a plantação pessoas pensam
que é que entra a maré neve já está
fazendo ao dia ser mais de visitar nas
marinhas mais ter mais uma experiência
disse preverem né aceitará imaginava
muita gente não sabe
os poucos minutos que existem tentar ser
humildes fazer pouco mas com qualidade e
nos ao da renapi possível salvar
expansão popular para
é só mais um minuto
essa vossa atenção é de verdade agora
aqui sugestão e o que nós podemos fazer
não é para preservar a nossa ria de
aveiro das nossas marinha e nós ao há
milhares de anos atrás muitas
civilizações consideravam sal como ouro
branco
atualmente não é assim o valor do sal
não dá pra manter as marinhas e por isso
mesmo elas estão a desaparecer
mas o sal tem um valor o valor cultural
eu marco geografia e marca uma história
nós associei aliado-chave isso peço
desculpa é o sol da ria de aveiro é
produzido num ecossistema único como
exibir a diversidade enorme de nos
associarmos estes ao um turismo de
natureza nós podemos criar um sistema
sustentável e assim preservar o nosso
sal
queremos associar também programas de
degustação de produtos da ria de aveiro
e podemos associar programas de
observação da fauna e da flora da ria de
aveiro
estamos assim valorizar a nossa história
a nossa tradição é nossa cultura é nossa
geografia estamos a passar gerações
futuras
os tanques das marinhas são tanques
reservatórios d'água curry ados murdoch
podemos fazer viveiros prestes privados
e assim também construir essas economias
paralelas que allen trazerem
enriquecimento enriquecer economicamente
a região é também fazem com que se cria
novas novos valores que se preserve a
nossa cultura nossa história e acima de
tudo que preserva o nosso sol que nós
teimamos em manter ou na alma
muito obrigada